on the morning of March 28th Domingo
Vega of Queens New York went to the
hospital with symptoms of pneumonia and
tested positive for kovat 19
this is Domingo but not just him this
light represents 500 people who have
been infected with the novel coronavirus
in New York City by May 16th there were
nearly a hundred ninety thousand known
cases of covin 19 their health officials
report these numbers every day in cities
and countries around the world but they
know that they're incomplete because
kovat testing has been like an arrow
flashlight in a dark room anything we're
not pointing the light at we can't see
but now researchers are collecting data
that can capture the pandemic more fully
to try to get a better handle on just
how much we've lost
[Music]
domingo vega died on April 16th at the
age of 45 originally from Mexico he came
to the US when he was 16 and worked in
restaurant kitchens since then
eventually launching his own business
with two locations in Brooklyn he and
his wife had three children Domingo was
one of 20,000 720 New Yorkers whose
lives were cut short by the corona virus
as of May 16th according to the city's
count each blue light represents 500
known deaths from Cova 19 and 500
families who don't need data to tell
them how dangerous this disease can be
[Music]
but when it comes to the statistics that
question how deadly is koban 19 has been
difficult to answer the relationship
between the known deaths and the known
cases is called the case fatality rate
at this point in New York City one out
of nine people known to have covin 19
have died that's eleven percent but that
rate varies drastically across cities
and countries it was over 12% in sweden
in mid-may but less than a percent in
iceland and it also changes over time
for the u.s. it dropped down to 1% near
the end of march before climbing back up
as people who tested positive several
weeks prior ended up dying when the case
fatality rate varies this much it's
saying a lot more about these countries
than about the disease itself for
example deaths may be higher in places
where the health system is overwhelmed
or where the population is older
we know that kovat 19 is more deadly in
seniors than especially those over 75
but also on the other side of the
fraction the rate reflects how much
testing is happening if a country is
aware of more non-fatal cases their case
fatality rate is lower so this statistic
isn't all that useful because we know
most countries are missing cases and
we're learning that we're also missing
deaths according to an estimate by the
New York Times there have been thousands
of deaths that weren't included in the
official count for New York City we
don't know for sure if it was
coronavirus that killed them but here's
what we do know
if you look at 2017 2018 and 2019 and
chart the average number of deaths per
week the line looks like this it
includes deaths from all causes for 2020
so far that line of weakly deaths looks
like this the area above the typical
level is called excess deaths by
researchers and it gives us a fuller
picture of the cost of this pandemic
we're seeing excess deaths in many
places that have suffered big outbreaks
in each case the excess deaths are
higher than the official count of kovat
deaths it includes people who may have
died from other causes but who were
unable or unwilling to access medical
care because of the pandemic but it also
includes some people with coronavirus
who weren't counted because they died at
home or in care facilities or were never
diagnosed as this data comes in it shows
us that in some places the pandemic is
even more deadly than we thought but the
virus itself may be less deadly because
we're also learning that a lot more
people have been infected than the
official tallies show health officials
in New York have taken small blood
samples that people at grocery stores to
check for kovat antibodies this is
called a cero prevalence survey and it
helps capture the substantial number of
people who didn't know they ever had
corona virus so far these tests show
that around 20% of people in New York
City tested positive for antibodies that
indicate a previous kovat infection if
those shoppers are representative of the
city's population
that would mean there were more than one
and a half million Kovan 19 cases in the
city by early May without changing how
many people have died the antibody
survey lowers the fatality rate by
identifying more non-fatal cases
remember the case fatality rate was 11
percent or one and nine but the fatality
rate for all of those who've been
infected may fall somewhere between 1
and 60 and one and 90 for New York City
so while the death count is higher than
we thought
the death rate may be lower
but a low fatality rate is not all good
news it paints a picture of a tricky
virus that moves undetected through many
of us and causes immense suffering and
death and others we can look for
comparisons to try to wrap our heads
around the death toll more people lost
in three months in the u.s. than a
year's worth of car crashes or drug
overdoses still fewer than the annual
deaths from cancer or heart disease but
the comparisons are limited because
unlike car accidents in cancer kovat 19
is contagious human beings are the
vector for this disease and their
actions are hard to predict so even with
better data on how many are infected and
dying we won't know the full death toll
of this pandemic until we find out how
it ends
[Music]
you